communities on the border are feeling
the impact of the surge of migrants
gila ben arizona is one of them the town
expects migrants to be released by
border patrol there
this week the town's independent mayor
chris riggs joins me now mayor riggs
thanks so much for joining us
explain to the audience your main
concerns at this point
at this point what we're looking at is
we're a
very economically depressed community
we can barely afford to take care of the
people that we have here
in our community now and
as of uh the second border patrol
advisors they're basically going to drop
people off here
and do sort of like this and they're
your problem
and we just do not have the ability
to care for these people and quite
frankly
it's going to cost us tens of thousands
of dollars a year
to be able just to provide them with a
bottle of water and a sandwich
when they get dropped off because
they're not able to give us how many
they can't give us what the background
on these people
are they can't tell us what their health
issues are
i've got a lot of seniors and elders
here and uh between gila band and our
san lucy
village that are very susceptible to
coven
and now you're going to drop people off
here we haven't had
seen the outbreak that other areas in
arizona have seen
yet we're going to get punished for
their their choices
well i'm sure you've expressed these
concerns uh to
to to i guess it would be ice and even
the biden administration
are they saying well we'll provide you
with something and you've got to be able
to know medical history to a degree
you've got to be able to take
temperature checks you have to be able
to make sure
no one has covet 19. you've got to know
criminal records i mean are you
completely in the dark
we are completely in the dark and we've
asked documentation
some kind of documentation give us
something and we're still not getting
anything
so i mean we're really very frustrated
with how we're being treated um for a
crisis
that they started
when you say day who do you mean federal
government
so do you feel that they've
yeah they've signaled to people if you
come here
you make it through you're you're more
or less home free
exactly and now we're seeing just
in the past few weeks we've seen a a big
increase in foot traffic
coming in through gila bend um i live
right
my my backyard literally is the sonoran
national monument
i like to take walks out there and i'm
seeing the foot traffic
come through here i'm seeing drug mules
like i've never seen before
go through our desert it needs to stop
it needs to stop and the federal
government government needs to step up
and do their job they're the ones who
created this problem
they need to fix it you know what i
found interesting is reading about
just your town and some of your
neighboring small towns the unusual
mix of not not your usual asylum seekers
from cuba from brazil from africa from
haiti from romania
it feels like the word is out around the
world if you find a way to get down to
mexico
will and you have enough money we'll get
you into the into united states
you're seeing people from the african
continent you're seeing people from the
middle east you're seeing people from
asia you're seeing a mix of people and
this is another big concern that we have
is not just covid19 but any other
disease
that can be brought in here because
they're not getting tested they're not
giving us any kind of documentation
so it puts my community at risk
and quite frankly i was elected to worry
about gila ben
not about anything outside of gila bent
and i need to focus on this community
well mayor you know i googled the 14
things to do when you're in gila bend so
hopefully one day we'll get all this
settled and
we can come down and give you a visit
thank you very much and good luck with
everything
thank you